good evening everyone
the ninth annual Academy of Motion
Picture
since Sciences governors awards us
[Applause]
special thanks to Governor David Rubin
and his dedicated staff for producing
this evening celebration and for making
this a night too long remember I also
want to thank the 54 extraordinary men
and women representing the Academy's 17
branches we'll all of our esteemed
governor's please stand so we can thank
you for your tireless work
[Applause]
I hope you look closely everybody this
may have been the only time you see all
of us respond in unison this is my first
Governor's Award celebration as your
Academy president and I'm privileged to
join you tonight to honor five artists
whose work and careers have inspired us
all this is the Academy's 90th year and
it reminds me that these awards honor
filmmakers who have touched us beyond
measure for decades we do these awards
for them yes but as well for those who
will inherit their visions today's
emerging talents some of whom we meet in
the Academy's outreach and intern
programs and some not yet born future
filmmakers who will become the next from
that royzman lar de sutherland in yachty
to you all can help us find and foster
new talent tonight's honorees have each
added a singular voice to the chorus
that is world cinema this evening we
don't simply give them an Oscar we give
them our deepest respect for the
enduring legacy of work they have shared
this world to director Charles Burnett
[Music]
a cinema poet whose journey took him
from the Mississippi Delta to the
streets of South Central LA and beyond
who takes us on new journeys to places
in our own City among our fellow
citizens living parallel lives as many
of us war passed them on elevated
freeways - Owen Weisman
a five-time Academy Awards
cinematography nominee for such great
films as a French Connection The
Exorcist and Network
[Applause]
Owens an artist whose technical
innovations camera style and lighting
have always set an invariable standard
to which all we cinematographers aspire
and whose iconic images inspire and also
haunt us Tonya's Florida
News Trailblazer icon a woman who
launched a cinema movement
a woman who launched a cinema movement
with her first feature La Pointe Courte
years before her male French colleagues
an artist whose work remains at the
cutting edge of cinema and whose films
have shown us that the most personal
visions can also touch popular audiences
for pushing the boundaries and pushing
our buttons we say on yes dude no
Felicity osteons
and to the inimitable chameleon-like
thomas southern one
whom I worked with on ordinary people
where he played Calvin father of the
Jared family riven by the loss of a son
again and again Donald has moved us with
the astounding range of his characters
from Hawkeye Pierce and Robert Altman's
mash to John Baxter and Nick rogues
don't look now
from fellini's Casanova to Hunger Games
President Snow the movies of these four
artists have set a high bar for us to
emulate and even as evolving technology
leads us forward they remind us that
some things never go out of style truth
humanity vision and heart but so too
does the work of the artist to whom we
tonight give a rare special Oscar
statuette Alejandro Gonzalez Inarritu
[Applause]
[Music]
Alejandro is a filmmakers whose
intensely emotional vision is
custom-made for times like now if you've
been to the Los Angeles County Museum of
Art to experience his multimedia work
time in a yalena
to walk in virtual reality in the
footsteps of Mexican migrants crossing
the desert of our American Southwest in
search of a new life you will feel in
your body
cinemas ability to transcend place and
politics to touch our shared humanity
tonight's honorees
inspired the next generation of
filmmakers with the same sense of wonder
and enchantment that first touched us
all they lift us up with their images
and their words reminding us to
creativity conscience and conviction the
very heart of film remains as powerful
today as they were more than 100 years
ago when a group of rag-tag cinema
pioneers abandoned the cliffs of Fort
Lee New Jersey for the sunny climes of
Southern California and created
Hollywood movies and so from the Academy
90 years young a toast to our honorees
we ask you all to lift up your to lift
us up once more as we raise our glasses
to you and to the movies that are our
lives Cheers
thank you and have a great evening
[Applause]